It's the general good experience
no matter what you call it.
I was like,
that's going on right now to be in Venice
for anywhere or in Hollywood for just
even just standing up there.
I'm on the right.
Look around here.
You know what?
I have coyote problems out here.
Occasionally there's a mountain lion
spotting a lot of hawks brown going to be
where?
Deer everywhere.
This is,
I like it out here man.
This is quiet and this is not
quite enough for me because I want,
I want to live in the fucking woods.
I have a very distinct idea of the
difference between my private life and my
personal life or my,
uh,
my public life and my public life.
I love working for the UFC.
I loved doing standup comedy,
but both of those things involve large
numbers of people and constantly being
around large numbers of fucking inverse
thousand people in this audience at the
UFC and you know,
and all these fucking people that you
see at comedy shows and all these people
in Vegas.
I like.
How do you take pictures after shows?
Short man,
all the time.
I just go out.
When I do a comedy show,
I uh,
we wait about five or 10 minutes to
cool off and I'd go out and I think I'll
stay for hours.
Pictures.
Yeah,
but,
but to go from that,
you want like a quiet
man living by the ocean,
living by the lake,
living more [inaudible]
people just can fucking chill.
You know,
we've talked about this before.
You don't have to live in populations,
sentence centers anymore,
you know,
not big major ones like La [inaudible]
comic if you want to do films was the
last time you filmed
the film in Hollywood.
I know you'll do a TV show me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then you can Skype those.
Now people are skyping
in to Skype with David O.
Russell.
I got caught.
It's moving.
I didn't you because a,
I went to do standup and I put myself
on tape and said big mistake because
I can't talk about it.
Come on fucker.
Can't talk about it.
Two Oh folks,
I found out one of his coconut juice
is better than regular coconut water.
Why?
The reason is because it
comes from Thailand and they
have their own plantation
in Thailand because,
um,
we've tried water.
That's just pure coconut water.
Pure calls are going to want it.
They just crack open the Cogan airport.
No,
no,
not at all.
No.
Unsweet and it's fucking with the
wishes and preservative free and um,
uh,
it tastes way better than some
of the stuff that's similar.
It looks the same.
It's in the same kind of can,
but if he's like fucking bath water.
And so I emailed the people at c two.
I was like,
why is your stuff say tastes
so much better and sweeter?
It's from Thailand Tacos to his death.
Better Taco.
So there you go.
That you're interested in some delicious.
That's better.
Girl Trisha,
she's had a coconut juice.
Then get some c two O if you're
interested in Bryan County,
follow him on Twitter.
It's B.
R.
Y.
A.
N.
Callan.
I don't know where I got that
fucking don't worry about it.
And the genetic.
Do you even do work out?
That's my Irish Italian.
She crazy,
crazy.
My dance or jeans.
What's your favorite dance move?
I mean,
I got so many,
but probably just the push away.
Just the hush here.
What does that mean to
you when you do that?
I'm just pushing away negative energy
and then I'm bringing in positive energy
here.
So it's,
it's this move.
So don't try this at home
because it takes life.
See,
I,
I rock back like that
and now we're taking in.
So,
uh,
I sent myself through college
doing some private dancing.
It makes me nuts.
When people say that some of
themselves who call it playing pool,
it's going on the fuck you did.
This was bubbling up a
little bit right now.
When your,
your legs or arms that never mind.
That's a pretty bad.
This one must be,
I'll get some,
ain't gonna want to eat some ink.
Are you confident off still at the point
where I was from out of town is drawing
anybody.
I don't know what I want.
I get tired of it.
I'm like,
why do you think Gregor's
didn't look so great?
That's what Joe wrote.
I mean,
uh,
that's what I dot.
David off I go,
what do you all attentive as he was?
Because I don't want
to look like an agent.
And they went online and I was like,
he's silly.
Brian.
Count silly to that's right.
Silly in a good way to tell.
I make my living.
We're going to eventually get dry.
Brian count do his own fucking podcast.
I'm doing low it up.
He swears to God like all
these other things here.
I do a lot of Jujitsu and I'm
fucking punch in boxing lore.
He's got it all folks been shaken.
I turned my at my startup death
valley fighting downstairs on MTV.
What's it like working for MTV?
Ah,
money.
A lot of money.
They just,
they with a wheelbarrow.
You get a 0.8.
You're not making any money.
I did.
I,
Um,
I was just recurring because I didn't
want to sign up a contract cause otherwise
they own you,
they own you and they won't
let you do other feminists.
So I make,
I think I can buy,
I can not,
I can go out to dinner
twice and buy a VCR.
Where's the,
uh,
is there anybody that's become famous
from MTV and the most read people but as
Jersey shore MTV who was,
wow,
I didn't,
why don't think it was like
Bravo or 16 and pregnant.
Huge.
Yeah,
but they don't give up the shackles.
The first piece is the first they
said it makes starts now Pam,
this is the first time.
Yeah.
This is actually the first show.
One of the first scripted shows.
Who says that?
That was always at the motto for MTV but
they make sure people now they'd have
to pay them.
Huh?
No hilarious hundred totally towels.
They also make money going to clubs
and Oh and and sponsoring a party.
So we'll,
we'll give you 40 grand,
50 grand just to come to this,
to,
to this club.
This nightclub will make
an appearance of Paris.
Hilton made millions that way.
Whole areas.
That's it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Brian Collins on the podcast,
follow him on Twitter and eventually
falling on the Bryan count experience.
Right at the front counter is Paula
and my friend is whether or not it's nice.
I like,
we get pretty hot up here too.
Is My favorite.
I like la in the winter
because there's actual weather,
you know?
I liked when it rains out there man,
but it's weird.
How did you ever think like you,
you grew up in Phoenix.
Do you ever think that you could live
in a place like Seattle where it rained
all the time?
Do you ever think about it?
I could,
but
I think once you're
around it for that long,
you would start to hate it.
Yeah.
You know,
just like just like the people in Seattle.
I mean there's a lot of people from
Seattle live in Arizona and they just want
to get out of the rain because there's
not a lot of writing in Arizona and then
you know,
then they start to hate it after a while.
It seems like a place where you
can only live for a little while.
Like maybe you could do a year there,
but I think if you live there
for a long period of time,
you probably go crazy.
It'd be fun to go there and just write,
get all depressed.
Something about rain that
makes me want to write.
Like if really starts to rain,
I want to rush home and right.
So like,
yeah,
I got,
I got it dude.
I got to reign mix like
a rain writing mix.
Am I on my iPod?
Really?
Yeah.
So you like listen to like fake rain fall.
It's like real random.
No,
not like that.
Like there's just certain music sets.
The mood.
Yeah.
What is the rain mix?
It's a little bring it up.
Stuff like Dave Matthews band.
There's just some like really?
Yeah,
chill music.
Something that just makes me want
to write about sucking dicks.
And
she was like,
you purposely leave the
sticker on your hat.
Yes.
Is that,
what does that mean?
Don't shut us down bro.
I'm fucking two gangsters
or take off the tag.
There's this,
there's this famous video where like
there was this huge riot in some kind of a
high school assembly.
Like and after this fight they showed
what was on the floor and it was all those
stickers and white towels do you know to
like wipe off your forehead and put it
over your shoulder.
But it was just like at least
20 towels and like 30 stickers,
hats,
sticks.
How about these guys that
don't even bend their bill?
It's just raised.
It looks ridiculous.
Word choice.
That choice.
Not a wide choice.
I would never do it.
It's something about it
that just screams ethnic.
Right?
Why is that?
So this is this crafting since the crafty
move they can get a lot of chances and
not all of them work.
Remember when people were wearing the
clothes backwards cause the Kris kross
jump didn't work,
didn't work.
It worked for a little while,
for a bunch of times for those,
there's some days where you can go to
the mall and see kids walking around with
the pants on backwards or they
shaved the Z Z cover each year.
I had a pair off calvary cheese at one
point in time that were like almost like
elastic here and they pulled in tight
and snug here and then they got to hear
and they puffed out the
puffed out and it was great.
Walk around and if you want
to dance some nice motion.
Josh McDermitt.
Ladies and gentlemen
follow Josh on Twitter.
It's [inaudible].
It's a tricky spelling.
Changing that for the public.
I want to change it to Ott,
but there's too many dudes out.
What?
Ott?
Yeah,
you know me to change it to that.
You should leave it alone.
Look Swartz now you can get through.
Come on son.
I'm going to change it to Josh.
Coco Diaz,
we it just,
Joe
should Jitsu representation by Joe Diaz.
Joe Diaz.
We just got done with the podcast,
another fantastic performance
by the Great Joe Diaz.
Finance human being on earth.
Loose.
You let me loose.
You know what I'm saying?
People don't want to let me loose.
They want to put the cross in front of me.
[inaudible] radio this
morning and I said Shit.
And they asked me to stop,
stop swearing and stuff.
I was so,
I'm so sorry.
I'm so used to doing my
podcast and then I said fuck.
And then I said,
shit again.
That's an asshole.
Yeah,
they had me on for 50 minutes,
man.
You had me on the phone for
50 minutes and you know,
I started getting passionate talking
about fighting and you know this and that
match ups and you know,
one guy,
his attributes and another guy's,
he's got the counter that and I
get crazy and I start swearing,
but it's because of the podcast.
You get so used to just
expressing yourself.
It's hard.
Yeah.
Talking normal.
It's really hard,
man.
When I go on regular radio shows and I
always go on bullet [inaudible] when was
the last time you get a radio
show and you weren't high?
Was that I did anything.
It wasn't hot,
but it's pointless to do radio.
That marijuana is a conversation enhancer.
I mean,
you don't want to go,
you're right there.
You don't want to go so
high that you can't talk.
You know,
you gotta be careful.
I've done that before.
It got so high that I can't formulate
proper sentences and I'm like,
oh,
I can't talk right now.
My goal is to get new Chuck's tomorrow.
That's how I want to start getting,
I want us to be able to go chess.
Like Nick Diaz.
Did you ever see the video that
mother fucker with known Chael is good.
That's when you know your Beth.
He put the video private
on youtube though.
The best video,
the best video was,
he was on the conference call.
He was supposed to be fighting,
think it was mine as a romps gifts.
I think this is a romps kiss.
He's supposed to be fighting the romps
gifts and he's on a conference call and
like he like leads in the compost pile.
I was like,
you know,
I just,
uh,
I ain't no bitch.
You know,
I'll fight fight.
They steps away from the conference
call and you hear him hit the bar,
you can hear him hit the bug and then
he comes back and he starts doing noon
chucks.
So while they're on this conference call,
he's got the thing on and they're
asking him questions and he's out there
fucking do it.
Noon checks as high as fuck and he button.
And he says he's got a
way to clean himself out.
He said he just stopped
smoking weed 10 days out.
He said 10 days ago.
Yes.
But he has no body.
Finally,
there's so much cardio.
He doesn't even let it get to the cells.
But the only time that he didn't do that,
who was a the gummy fight,
he tested positive for the gummy fight
and they said there was so much weed in
his system when they tested him that
he had to be high when he was fighting.
So what he did was just get
just completely ripped and then
went out there and fought tack,
annoyed,
go me and just outbox and pride and
feel bad and then submitted him.
Hey,
it's safer over there.
No,
I want it submitted him.
You can pick up on how
many things should do.
Think about what level.
I mean,
you know,
you didn't do,
you'd have like smoked and got on stage.
And also when they,
you asking me and I said try it
once a long time ago by accident.
I don't only smoke pot and maybe a half,
a dozen times in my whole life until I
was 30 and it was usually like at a party
I had a couple of drinks or whatever.
And that's what happened.
Once I was at,
uh,
my roommates and I,
one of one of my roommates
friends with is the January,
always smoked weed.
And so we all over the house and
I didn't smoke weed at the time,
but we're thinking,
what the hell,
you know,
all right,
everybody's smoking a little weed,
I'll take a hit.
So I took a hit and I got super high
and I was super paranoid and I was like,
oh my God,
I gotta go do comedy like this.
And I was really nervous to go do comedy.
I'm like,
I'm way too hard and
going on stage or not,
I can't believe this.
I don't mode if I forget my material.
And I went up and Slade and it's like a
half feel for this material that I never
had before,
but that was a long time ago.
And then they get to do it
again until I was like 38.
If you got to that level and you
could go in the ring and fight,
oh yeah,
I would do it just for the sake of it.
At that point,
especially against GSP,
I get it fucking stoned.
Just enough like it's just see the punches
because you just get in the zone like
he was doing against Bj Penn.
He was just turning to
walking on him and sometimes,
yeah.
How about when he stuck
his chin out and he's like,
it was fucking crazy.
Let and Bj Punch.
I'm like,
God,
I sold a fight man,
and he's up in his GSP
and that's all that is.
Well,
dude,
after the fight was over,
he was walking in the ring
and he's putting a shirt on.
He said,
well,
you act.
George met George.
He's putting his shirt.
I was like,
well,
you at George,
like he just beat the fuck out
of Bj Penn and he's not happy.
He's walking around the ring going,
where are you at George?
Will you act George like yelling at the,
at the look,
look into the camera.
Well,
you at George,
he sold it because George
St Pierre was so mad.
He sold,
he was so mad.
George St Pierre,
who's like,
please let me fight him.
He so disrespectful.
George wanted to fight him and he said,
he was like,
ah.
He had this expression in French.
It's the French equivalent to,
you've got to strike while
the iron is hot and it's true.
You know,
if they fought,
you know,
if he fought Carlos
condit and then Nick Diaz,
fuck someone else.
Somebody could lose,
you know,
calls candidates got down killer.
Anybody can lose Carlos condit,
you know,
and who the hell knows and somebody
might be able to be Ellenberger.
Ellenberger might be
able to beat Nick Diaz.
He might take them down.
He might,
he might knock them out and
mean we were fucked house.
If fights are crazy,
man,
anything can happen in a fight.
But got Damn Nick Diaz
is exciting addition.
He's an exciting addition.
He's crazy.
It goes to going to sell the most
paper views really ever seen.
Ever dark.
Do you know how great the press
conference is going to be with nick?
If he shows,
if he shows he shows Davis.
I said,
don't fire me.
I'm ready.
I'm done.
I ain't no bitch.
I ain't no black.
Stay black.
What's love stay black.
[inaudible]
yeah,
yeah.
That's not good.
Is that like a Mike Tyson mask?
Is that what's it look like?
It right.
No,
like a distorted money monster.
Buton Mike Tyson because he said that
Mike Tyson lie off each asshole a lot.
Bitch.
It's like a famous Tyson line.
That's not a good song.
I mean,
I wonder what happened.
Maybe they became famous and
then they started to suck.
It happens to people.
It's good when the girls
seeing it's kind of cool.
Really just like the rap
doesn't move fast enough.
Well not only that,
the whole fucking in the ass thing.
Dj had tickets [inaudible]
like who let them?
Who didn't say no?
This is dom.
I was saying this,
what you're talking about that,
where's it,
who's his manager?
Is there
someone who edits the software,
listens to it.
Who like assesses their work.
You know,
they assessed that and we won and I'm
pretty happy with this Dj Hyde type of
fucking in the ass.
You Jihad tech.
We'll fucking ass.
He's got a heart attack.
The fucking like,
you're probably going to like
this song in two weeks though.
No Way.
You'll hear it again.
No,
that's a bad song,
dude.
That's dumb.
I love them.
I think you're great,
but I just think that it just,
it's got weird rhythm.
So Sam Aaa,
another episode of the
podcast we just got done.
That was great to be back
in headquarters in Tripoli,
Peck,
and we're going to be gigging again too.
Very excited you man.
Oh,
anytime you as classic Naoc weekend.
Yeah.
Yossi weekend in San Jose.
I'm very excited.
Good Times.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we've got a crazy podcast week,
so we're going to keep it short.
Sam Tripoli,
checking out.
Enjoy the restaurant.
We on Twitter,
Tri p.
O.
L.
Y.
Sam first.
Figure it out.
Figure it out and make it happen.
Hi,
I think we've stepped into a time machine,
so I'm going to show you.
David tells phone,
look at David.
Tell cell phone.
We show us.
We show America yourself.
Please show the flip up.
All right,
we just did a the podcast and now what?
This is what we do,
a little video blog thing
that we do with pocket rental.
You're talking about,
well,
it's all about getting
content to the freaks.
Make the connection to people.
I say,
you know what I'm saying?
I like the sunglasses.
Fuck it.
And especially at night it'll warrior.
I'm ready to fucking look at
fish through the water polarized.
This is where they did the
mock up training compound.
I'm bidding on right out.
I just want to go home before
you came up with the camera.
Dave and I were talking about uh,
like recognizing old school comedians and
like we're both kind of historians and
we were,
we were trying to figure out whether or
not we were being honest with ourselves
and where are they that good and where
we're trying to build them up but we're
trying to keep it alive
and let people know.
I think we're trying to keep
it alive and let people know.
Yeah,
I was just going to say
that like what's it,
it's not so much building them up cause
they weren't great but it's like are
they going to be as great
to this next generation?
Probably not because they have their own
people that they will have a chance to
watch a Lenny Bruce uh,
record.
It's hard.
It's hard but you got to like,
you know,
see it from that perspective.
Cause comic does an age like music.
So that's what it is,
you know?
Yeah.
Comedy,
except for the stooges,
man,
they bring it hard.
Every little rascal is
really close to my face.
Fisheye.
He said it looks like it's right,
but I'm no,
I was just thinking like,
oh we,
oh we overplaying it to these younger
cats who don't really give a shit or are
we just like,
you know,
some of them do the right fight
and you know some of them,
some of them are going to you,
but that's because people are
going to complain about everything.
So I figured it was a comedy fan,
you know?
That's all right.
Well listen man,
when I,
before I was a comic,
you know,
I mean I've always been a comedy fan,
but before I was a comic,
when I was a comedy fan,
I wouldn't want to hear
and heard this stuff.
Oh yeah.
Right.
I heard it know you're a comic.
Oh God.
Oh Steve Martin.
Just sitting around every
week doing three times.
That'd be amazing.
How awesome would it be
to watch Steve Martin too?
I was there.
I saw him a couple of times,
see Kennison live.
I never saw him say.
That's one of my regrets.
I wish I had seen him live.
I saw Kennison live three times,
I think once when he was still hot.
And then once at the end where he was
just was rock Russell Good anymore?
Yeah,
it was bad.
It was amazing.
It was like I go,
I got to watch the full metamorphoses,
the full,
you know,
getting sucked into Hollywood.
But at first saw him,
it was like 87 86 87 holy shit.
I saw him at Great Woods
Center for the performing arts.
God Damn,
he fucking destroyed.
He destroyed.
And he had this bit at the end where he
would take someone from the audience and
bring them on stage and they would tell
a story about how some girl broke her
heart and call it,
pull out a phone and call it.
Yeah Dude,
he was a,
he crushed,
he crushed.
Everybody just left.
They're shaking their heads like,
God damn,
he's the one guy that
you can watch and not.
And now we're doing it again.
But this is true to me.
This is my truth with a,
with watching him,
it's like he's the one guy
that I think never got,
never was respected as
a comic because his,
his rock and roll life
overplayed his comedy.
But when I watched him to this day,
I feel like he's right in the room with
me in my fucking phase and I'm shaking
with like,
just fucking power.
It's his power,
you know,
he's like bang,
Bang,
Bang.
And I love that [inaudible]
says is fucking just man.
It's just like he's painting
pictures up there and I love it.
Yeah.
And did it,
nobody had done it again
about hearing this shit.
Yeah.
He,
when I first saw him,
uh,
on the,
the first HBO special,
I maintain it.
That's the best comedy
I've ever seen in my life.
Still to this day.
His Rodney or no,
no,
no.
His first one is,
first is our special,
when he did a,
you know,
that Jesus on the cross
and the fucking thing that
he would do about the,
the,
the homosexual necrophilia acts in the,
come on,
man.
That's some of the basket is great.
Ever saw and it was nobody was
anything like that beforehand?
No.
It was total paradigm shifting.
Screaming rage,
rage.
No fucking yes.
Right.
And you would just,
you just get sucked into it.
It's like a different kind of comedy.
It was completely different
than anything I'd seen before.
You're absolutely right man.
Cause that special now.
Now I'm thinking about it.
He owned that fucking room.
He owned that stage.
Went from being a preacher guy.
You fucking knew how to own it.
Fucking like everybody in the
room thought he's making iconic.
That's like a preacher thing where you
feel like he's talking to just you,
but he's talking to like a
couple of hundred people,
thousand people.
You the story bucking them.
It's really kind of crazy.
I read his book.
Did you ever read his book?
My brother Sam,
his brother Bill wrote a book about Shit.
I did read that book.
Yeah,
he got hit by a car when he was a
little kid and it totally changed his
personality.
He got fucked up by a car
and he got injured his head.
And after that became like reckless
and wild wasn't a different person.
So it's like he was created
almost by an accident.
I used to run into his brother,
like occasionally like doing things
like Montreal comedy festivals and stuff
like that.
And I always felt like I had
just gotten off and I felt like,
you know,
hey,
I really,
really nailed it.
And then I would see him and I'd be like,
you know,
like,
I'm sorry if I,
you know,
um,
nothing,
you know,
I felt like,
this guy actually saw like perfection.
Oh yeah.
When I first met,
uh,
due to worked with Hicks,
I was like one of the,
that's another one.
This one of the college as for myself
or you're just trying to do my things.
That's,
that's another great comedy club that
no longer is great or even going to the
laugh,
stop and use that.
Fortunately bones on that one.
That was great club.
That was one of those,
love that club.
Yeah.
Wild West shootout clubs
you got was just chaos,
man.
We had some fun times and that was sweet.
That was a sweet ride,
man.
That was it.
That was definitely like every you,
you look forward to that place.
And then of course I'm Craig Guy,
you know,
the glazer brothers and I,
and actually one of the,
one of the glazer brother's
just died in Kansas City.
Oh really?
You know,
um,
Craig.
Thanks brother.
Yeah.
Oh really?
Car Accident.
Yeah,
but no juice,
uh,
that David tell him down this week,
three days a radio.
Um,
you're up for it.
Right.
He would get you up.
You would have to do that
one local guy in Kansas City.
They don't like the big time
rock and roll guy in Kansas City.
His name.
Oh yes,
yes.
He hit Johnny blaze rise.
Johnny,
let me come on,
man.
It's a big supporter of comedy.
He's a good guy.
Johnny blaze.
And how cool it that you
can't get cooler than that.
That was his name.
He's a local radio DJ.
His name's Johnny blaze
and he's cool show.
It's fun to do,
man.
I only did it once,
but it was fucking cool.
Yeah,
he was,
it was,
uh,
that,
that was another wild west comedy Kaplan.
So,
uh,
we're going down comedy history.
Somebody say,
well this is a bit Sony and you know,
you get to like fucking actually,
you know,
because we both know it
for us.
I think it's also like,
uh,
you know,
two soldiers out there in the world
that don't get a chance to meet
up to a ballerina.
Talk about ballerinas are
professional jazz players.
It can be a lot of pokey mon experts.
You,
you know,
you get together and you,
you could talk about shit
that we mentioned earlier.
Yeah.
Well we know it made us who we are,
but it was also like,
you know,
it'll never be that way again.
So it's like,
you know,
whatever.
In La Right now,
La has a pretty good helps that scene.
I really hope so.
It's one of the best
scenes in the country,
if not the best.
That's it's only on New York
is the only competition,
you know,
and it's all,
it's left.
It's New York and La.
That was pretty good right now.
But you know,
there's some kid out there
listen to your podcasts.
He's fucking brilliant.
Yeah,
and he's stepfathers yelling
at him right now and he's,
he's fucking working,
you know,
at staples.
But all in all night long.
He's just watching comedy central
fucking thing and the jokes.
That's the key.
Right?
He didn't make his debut.
I'm ready to group on a ticket for it,
dude.
All right.
Yeah,
there you go.
You know that's how it lays down.
I got to give you a really
good seeing you too,
buddy.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
So you think CIA fuck agents if
infiltrated occupy Wall Street,
CIA operatives,
CIA.
Did they show up again?
Bags.
Mr. Johnson,
come with me.
You're government needs you.
Hi,
I'm Joe Rogan.
That's Tom Score.
And this is Miss Secura.
Otherwise known as Christina Jet Ski.
I can't spell it.
I spell it right.
Pete A.
hilarious.
One,
two power comedy couple.
You guys are a one to fucking punch.
One,
two,
one,
two.
Comedy punchline.
Yeah.
You grew up man.
Grooming your neck.
Oh yeah,
go grow.
Look at this shit,
man.
I got to separate it
back in it and that here manly man.
That's
fucking Harry Savage.
And what you don't want to get up?
Well my how high this is about to get,
I also sweat a lot.
Yeah,
I can see you with a knife.
Thing of teeth climbing a rope
on the lady's sure.
Thanks.
What is your nationality?
Um,
more than half Spanish from Spain,
from Spain.
My mom is 100% Peruvian,
but she has Spanish and French blood.
There's gotta be some local
Indian English right there too,
I guess.
But she's mostly that.
My Dad is Spanish,
French and Irish.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's an interesting combination man.
Yeah.
And you said that's a funny thing
about Thomas and he speaks fluent
fashion and people have noticed
they talk a little shit around them.
As soon as a Mexican dudes
talk some shit around.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
That's why I turned to them.
You go
join my new favorite comic.
Funny Chord.
She
cheese.
Yeah.
Can you speak Mexican or
you speak some Hungarian,
which is
crazy language.
You would,
you would really enjoy this.
Hungarian has the,
uh,
all the languages that basically
they've done studies on has the most uh,
curse words and insults.
Really.
Some of the insults are so
imaginative or creative.
Tell him like,
say it can say the worst
thing is [inaudible].
It means your mother is leader of the
Horse and God fucks her and harass hall
and that's a common fuck.
Fuck you.
You're fucking dad says,
oh yeah,
I learned that.
But he said,
you say it,
you say it when you're driving.
It's like nuts.
A quarter by ish then boss,
some egg.
Oh,
quarterback.
[inaudible]
summary of what each then wow.
The first time she said it to me,
I was just like,
what are you doing tomorrow is a good one.
I like,
it's so economical.
Like you could say so much with this,
this Acorda each day.
Apostle man.
And what is the English translation?
Well,
it's just like your mother
is the leader of the horse.
She's a big whore and then got it.
Fucks her in her ass.
It's amazing that you
could see that so quick.
And I know do most of May to say your
mother is the leader of the horrors and
God,
fuck sure.
So
if you tried to say that
to somebody in English,
they'd be like,
you want to wrap it up?
I do.
Where you know we have the ribbon or
even comedian trickles down to like the
Christmas carols for kids.
It's funny though because the
Christmas Carol like it's silly,
but kids know it was the Christmas Carol.
Sure.
Yeah.
You should say hey and
goes as she got a whole
sidewalk.
Khakis.
Chico.
Okay,
so that's what you teach like yellow kids,
right?
What does it mean?
It means the snow is falling
and all the cows are,
oh,
I'm sorry.
All the forces are farting
and the littlest horse.
Why Christmas?
It's like a fun song.
Blew the fuck is wrong
with the rest of the world.
This is the reason why man can need to
be the guiding light lead the rest of the
fucking world out of
the Goddamn Stone Age.
No.
Anyway,
Christina P on Twitter,
you can follow her.
Christina,
pee on Twitter and Tom
Segura Seg Ura my pals.
Thanks.
You do the podcast,
you guys,
you guys are the shit fun one to
the Joe Rogan experience.
[inaudible].